the idea of thanksgiving was a part of
her vision of
amer creating an american culture
thanksgiving was very popular in new
england of course and she had grown up
loving the holiday there were
thanksgivings celebrated in the other
states and territories as well
but the uh they were um
the governors of the states didn't
coordinate on the holiday each was and
sometimes some states didn't bother to
celebrate at all
so you had a situation for example in
1837 hale was living in boston which
celebrated on one day she was from new
hampshire which celebrated on another
day and her magazine was headquartered
in
philadelphia and pennsylvania wasn't
celebrating at all that year
so her vision was
to have americans celebrate on the same
day every year
she thought that giving thanks
the idea of giving coming together to
give thanks
as
as a nation
would um help um
she had it had a higher moral principle
she believed and that it would bring the
country together in a positive way
and as the country moved closer to civil
war she hoped that it would prevent
that war
i'm dave rubin and joining me on this
very special week is a senior fellow at
the hudson institute author of
thanksgiving the holiday at the heart of
the american experience and the
presenter in the prageru video lincoln
and thanksgiving melanie kirkpatrick
welcome to the reuben report
it's wonderful to be with you especially
uh on thanksgiving week it seemed like
you were the person to talk to on
thanksgiving i have a lot of questions
about thanksgiving you're the are you
the preeminent thanksgiving expert in
america well i i i i don't want to sound
immodest but uh perhaps so
pretty good all right so i have a lot of
questions about tryptophan but i think
you mostly want to focus on uh the
history of thanksgiving is that correct
sounds like a good idea though
tryptophan has come up uh you know uh
it's one of the reasons everybody loves
thanksgiving it helps put you to sleep
puts you to sleep you unbuckle the pants
you're good to go all right so let's
talk because this actually is a very
special thanksgiving thanksgiving 2021
this is the 400th anniversary of
thanksgiving i feel like a lot of people
don't know that so let's do a little 101
what happened 400 years ago back in
1621 first thing i'll mention is that
there are two eyewitness accounts by
pilgrims of the first thanksgiving and
neither one of them uses the word
thanksgiving
which is kind of interesting that's been
imposed on it over the centuries
the um but it it meets with uh it
dovetails with the pilgrims idea of what
a thanksgiving is it's a day for
uh expressing gratitude it was always a
religious holiday
but the the event of 1621 uh was
probably more of a harvest festival but
that doesn't mean we can't call it a
thanksgiving because uh if you read
those two first first-person accounts
and by pilgrim edwin edward winslow and
william bradford the governor of
plymouth colony
it they present
an event that was very much like the one
we celebrate today at least in spirit
the spirit of gratitude was
at the forefront it was the spirit of
amity with the native americans
it was a time of
sharing it was a time of fellowship
and it was a time of peace
and one of the things i object to is the
modern day progressive
interpretation of that day as the
beginning of
a um period a period you know the
destruction of the native american
peoples and that's completely wrong
because
if anything the first thanksgiving
points the way to the multicultural
people we have become
because the native americans and the
indians were celebrating together
peacefully and in harmony
yeah so it's hard for a lot of people to
believe that and i don't want to dwell
on it because it's not true you discuss
it in the book you discuss it in the
prageru video but can you just just for
another minute or two just explore that
a little bit that you know people have
this idea that they they were just there
to kill each other or whatever it is
whatever the modern version of all this
is but really 400 years ago the native
americans and the pilgrims were sitting
down and they were
saying hey we can be thankful together
on this land peacefully together yes yes
they were and um the pilgrims had a lot
to be thankful for for the the
assistance of the native americans they
would not have they probably would not
have survived had they not received the
instruction from the native americans on
how to plant where to find good hunting
grounds and good fishing waters
so
and and they knew it they
uh
there were 52 pilgrims present at that
first thanksgiving and um
most of the only about half of them were
men and yet there were 90 uh indian
warriors present
so
you can see why they might have been a
little wary and that was probably one
reason that they decided to
have
a
a shooting presentation they showed the
native americans you know how you know
their guns and how they could use them
and it might have been in part a warning
but at the same time um they were very
grateful for the help of the native
americans that made it possible for them
to survive
so you tell the story of thanksgiving
because it didn't it didn't exactly
become a holiday right then and there
that there are two sort of people that
were integral to the story of
thanksgiving one of the people we know
well one we don't know as well although
you just wrote a book i believe about
the second person so tell us about those
two people
oh the first one is president lincoln
and the second is sarah josefa hale and
the lincoln the link between the two of
them is thanksgiving hale was um
the most influential woman of the 19th
century she was editor of goatee's
ladies book
for 50 years and this was one of the
most
widely read and widely circulated
magazines in the uh 19th century and
it's kind of an amazing story of how a
widow with five five small children rose
to such an exalted position but she did
and uh she was very keen on
using uh well let me back up she was
born in 1788 and she believed
that
while america had been unified
politically through the revolution it
was not unified culturally and she set
out to help do that in her magazines
she
published american authors writing on
american subjects which seems unusual
from the point of view of the 21st
century but back then it was commonplace
for publications to
steal articles from britain or other
publications and republish them without
credit in their own publication but she
had a different vision for her magazine
she wanted to have focus on america and
a focus on american authors
so she published such authors as edgar
allan poe and harry the young harriet
beecher stowe and many many others
but
the idea of thanksgiving was a part of
her vision of um amer creating an
american culture thanksgiving was very
popular in new england of course and she
had grown up loving the holiday there
were thanksgivings celebrated in the
other states and territories as well
but the uh they were um
the governors of the states didn't
coordinate on the holiday each was and
sometimes some states didn't bother to
celebrate at all
so you had a situation for example in
1837 hale was living in boston which
celebrated on one day she was from new
hampshire which celebrated on another
day and her magazine was headquartered
in philadelphia and pennsylvania wasn't
celebrating at all that year
so her vision was
to have americans celebrate on the same
day every year
she thought that giving thanks
the idea of giving coming together to
give thanks
as um as a nation
would um help um
she had it had a higher moral principle
she believed and that it would bring the
country together in a positive way
and as the country moved closer to civil
war she hoped that it would prevent
that war
obviously she didn't succeed but in 1863
president lincoln took up her idea which
had been rejected by four previous
presidents and uh
decided to call a national thanksgiving
so basically it took over 200 years of
sort of a mis-mush of you know who's
doing it when are they doing it why are
they doing it and then finally lincoln
said okay we're all going to do it and
then did everyone kind of fall in place
and immediately say let's do it
yeah the south didn't want to listen to
lincoln during the civil war of course
but the union
rallied very positively to
his call and after the war um
the southern states um
slowly you know one by one came together
as well on thanksgiving day if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about academia instead of
non-stop yelling check out our academia
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell